in the 20th century the concept has been
that the schools are an expression of
society's values and interests and
should be imposed upon the child and the
child should be made to do what's good
for him and that the major problem in
schooling was to get the child out of
the hands of his ignorant in a ignorant
and not very sophisticated parents and
put the child in the hands of the
sophisticated and knowledgeable
educational experts who could guide him
along the correct way robert n low and
i'm the president of the friedman
foundation for educational choice it's
the legacy foundation of Milton Friedman
and his wife Rose our job is to
implement his vision of school choice
for all children in America so we want
to make sure all parents have the access
and the opportunity to choose any school
public private or charter in this
country our founder Milton Friedman is
the architect of the modern voucher
movement he started the idea in 1955 and
started our foundation in 1996 what we
need to do is to enable parents by
vouchers or other means to have more say
about the school which their child goes
to a public school or a private school
which ever meets the need of the child
best he is so important to this movement
for two reasons one he is the
intellectual heartbeat of this moment he
is the place that you go back to when
you talk about school choice for all
families and I think the second thing
that he's been the standard bear on is
starting a foundation the whole job is
to educate the public on the issue of
school choice Milton Friedman is the
best economist of the 20th century we
all know that but it wasn't just his
incredible rigorous thinking it was his
foresight into how to get things done
through organizations like ours into his
thinking around school choice we started
in 1996 and there's been steady growth
in school choice programs in states over
that time when we started there were six
programs operating in six states now
there are 34 programs operating in 17
states in DC last year in particular
2011 we actually had 19 school choice
programs enacted in 13 States eight were
brand new programs and 11 were
expansions of older programs so it was
an amazing year in 2011 we looked for
the same thing in 2002
well you know school choices has started
off sort of incrementally with lower
income families being able to choose and
our job is to make sure every family can
choose the people who lose most from
this system are the poor and the
disadvantaged in the large cities they
are simply stuck they have no
alternative a marketplace for education
is critically important for one simple
reason I mean it works right it name me
a business name me a product name me
anything where we don't have choices the
more choices we have the better the
products typically in the lower the cost
we have a simple problem in this country
and that's a monopoly it's not the
people in the system it's the system
itself competition is better than the
number the centralization produces
deadening uniformity it destroys the
experimentation that is a fundamental
source of progress so we want to mark a
place of options because we want as many
high-quality options as we can you've
got tons of private schools and tons of
charter schools tons of cyber schools
tons of good public schools and we need
to make sure parents have access to all
those schools because what we did in
this country a while ago would say hey
where you live is where you go to school
and nothing could be more unjust than
that and so a marketplace is needed to
basically bust up that entire unfairness
of our system all of the opposition to
allowing the market work comes from
people who have a very strong vested
interest in the present public school
system I am not proposing we are not
proposing to destroy the public school
system we are only asking that the
public school system should be free to
compete should be open to competition if
it is really as good as you people make
it out to be it has nothing to worry
about indiana in 2011 jump to the head
of the class of school choice so what we
did in Indiana with heat reforms of
teacher evaluation of collective
bargaining reforms and a school choice
and charter school expansion and this
whole package came together and was
passed by the legislature and what was
amazing about that was one it's a
statewide voucher program that extends
well into the middle class so now we
have families who have been struggling
to send their kids to private schools
for years who've been struggling but
aren't quite fit the definition of being
truly poor according to federal
guidelines now we have those families
have been struggling so hard who
now have a little relief and you'd send
their kids to higher quality school 3919
kids signed up in the first year that's
the fastest growing first year voucher
program ever the trial court has just
upheld the constitutionality of the
program of sixty-nine percent of from
urban areas this is what you'd expect
the urban kids needed the most but
sixteen percent of from suburban areas
and fifteen percent are from rural areas
because it's brought income right you
would think that maybe the higher income
would be the ones to take at the most
but that's not what happened we Milton
Friedman was right again Mountain
Freeman said a universal program would
benefit the poor tremendously the middle
class somewhat and the rich hardly at
all well that's exactly what happened in
Indiana the voucher program forty-seven
percent white twenty-four percent
african-american nineteen percent
Hispanic you're more than twice as
likely as an african-american to be
attending a private school using a
voucher than you are in the state of
Indiana being attending a public school
we need to amp up the call for reform
across the country we need to really
make sure all the groups on the ground
that are doing their thing that we help
them do their thing better market
competition is the surest way to improve
the quality and promote innovation in
education as in every other field
you